all right welcome everybody we have a uh
sort of haphazardly planned um
press conference today which donald
trump announced just a little while ago
donald trump announcing
um where is this here important news
conference today by lawyers on a very
clear and viable path to victory
pieces are very nicely falling into
place rnc at 12 p.m
um i think donald trump certainly
doesn't believe this i think he's just
continuing the the facade at this point
continuing to tweet
absolute insanity um thousands of
uncounted votes discovered in georgia
counties when much more important
signature match takes place the state
will flip republican and quickly no
expectation that that will happen and in
fact
we are expecting that georgia may be
certified
literally during this press conference
that we're waiting for and that of
course there is speculation
that part of the reason for scheduling
this at exactly this time
is uh to try to be essentially counter
programming to the certification that we
are expecting if that happens
we will know about it we will see it and
we will have the final georgia recount
numbers for you remember
a recount was happening in georgia once
it's complete
the results are sort of certified
re-certified
and we're expecting that to be um
very very soon um
man i still am i'm so confused by the
things people put in the chat like
people who are asking
is there no show it's like aren't you're
in the chat you're watching
this is the show we're doing a show
right now what does that mean is there
no show we're
you're why how are you even chatting if
there was no show
um what is this channel come on guys
come on you're watching you're watching
right now
um oh i have no audio or video well how
do you know that i'm even on then that's
bizarre
okay i'm being told that c-span has the
live video of what's going on in the
room so i'm going to try to switch to
that
c-span rnc press conference
let's take a look uh live
two months ago that's not it let me see
if i can whoa hold on something
something just happened there
let's see if we can find it um
c-span live
and where is it
yeah i am not seeing it unfortunately
i wish i was c-span
trump campaign live
um yeah i'm just not
uh it's not coming up unfortunately
i am unable to find it but i believe we
will very very soon have live video here
and we're going to see it all
let me get to a few super chats and a
few thank yous big thank you to martha
baker
for signing up at joinpackman.com as
well as is
isabel wiborski who are new members one
and two today
at joinpacman.com we are also counting
twitch
subs of which there are two
25 21 which puts us at four
and people are texting me saying that
the press briefing is happening i know
that i'm streaming right now
so a lot of crazy things happening but
this listen we we threw this together
haphazardly
and and we are here uh all right trump
live
very very good and i guess people are
telling me right side broadcasting is
live that should just
out of curiosity let's just see what
right side broadcasting is putting up on
screen
uh okay they are live in the room
interestingly all right good
so we're standing by here this should be
very very interesting um i i expect
four what does four mean four minutes to
go
what a strange channel this is wow
how bizarre is that
okay anyway this is starting soon who
the hell knows what it is that they are
going to be
uh saying i assume it's by the way could
they have gotten a room with a lower
ceiling
is it is this a basement could was there
any room with a lower ceiling even
available or was this the one with the
lowest ceiling they found
um let's see uh isabelle says it's
wyborski i apologize isabel i want to
get everybody's names correct
sarah says hey david is live my partner
jesse me and our cats all love you
thank you bostonian parkman says two
months left we can do this
best of luck um stand up and fight back
says stand up and fight back
that makes sense i use arch as asking
who i
am which is a fair question jennifer
appreciates the live streams
zack wonders if trump will pardon the
turkey i believe he will
i believe he will chris changed his mind
and says you must hire
vaush instead of jenk thank you for
introducing me to him
and chakaseki says does anyone know how
chuck gaspley is doing
is he praying away the kovid with the
help of paula white
and ken copeland um very all very very
good questions which i appreciate
what is going on here this channel this
is just a very unprofessional channel
isn't it
here we go this is better well we got
right we've got to get off of this
they're just focusing in on one woman
it's very odd
all right this is better so now we will
be we will be aware right away when this
begins i do have one crazy voicemail to
play for you if you guys want
one crazy voicemail this is from the guy
we're
naming prickles guy because he always
calls me david prickles
do you guys want to hear the voicemail
i'm glad to play it
people demanding the voicemail all right
let's take a listen to it
i i have not pre-screened it but i would
get the kids out of the room typically
these are not
safe for work so to speak catboy
you flapping your arms around you're
gonna fly to venezuela
why don't you talk about the dirty
cocaine head
hunter biden and his corrupt
pay-for-play
father dysfunctional father so drug
addiction is of course
a medical issue and so i don't know what
you want me to talk about also hunter
biden is not
president and then you know the
allegations you're making against joe
biden i'm going to need some receipts on
those
joe you don't mention that do you you
democrats don't do
anything i'm not a democrat i've never
been a registered democrat
wrong you guys are they're so filthy
i hope they get a special counsel and i
hope they fry his ass
special special account what is he
talking about man that is
really really weaponized um
that's that's really bad uh and then i
also had
uh i don't know if i want to cut away
from this so we i don't want to miss
this but we had another
email that came in which i posted to my
twitter as well which is just
completely out of this world insane
big thank you to jason colts jason colts
has just signed up at joinpackman.com
and his new member number five just a
reminder that i say this with complete
peace and love
we have a new coupon code fresh start
and fresh start saves you 70
off of the cost of a membership so i
would encourage you to take advantage of
that
at joinpackman.com um
i guess we'll keep the volume up here
just so if we do move away from it we
won't miss it
also thanks to the uh
thanks to all of our twitch subscribers
as well i very much appreciate that one
new twitch subscriber
there as well everybody being it's
almost like it's a wedding everybody's
turning around like the bride is about
to walk down the aisle then you turn
back and it's rudy tucking in his shirt
some of these folks in the basement are
going to be disappointed and by the way
the the room they're in it's such a sad
room the ceiling is so
low that their flag display the
flagpoles
are almost hitting the ceiling if you
can imagine something more pathetic
i have no idea where this basement is is
this in georgia somewhere
legal advisor hold conference
yeah it doesn't say where it is uh let's
see if the
text vote to 88022 dear god
now i have no idea i mean maybe it's in
georgia because i thought it related to
georgia but i didn't think giuliani was
doing anything in georgia so who the
hell knows
it's just it really is sad i've never
bumped into anything in my life
okay other super chats trump's
prosecutor says the venue is one
flag from being an amusement park that's
nice i like that yeah it's almost
six flags that is absolutely correct
um it's at the rnc
it's in the basement of four seasons
landscaping yeah
they decided to move it from out front
at four seasons into the basement
edwards says laura ingram has a segment
asking to work with aoc
i'll check that out mel is predicting
fist shaking from giuliani if is
giuliani even going to be
at this i know it's being promoted as if
he is but i i don't know who's going to
be here it's very bizarre
joseph says trump called the female
republicans of wayne county board
she now wants to rescind her vote for
certifying the election results for
wayne county
um that's crazy if true trump is calling
vote certifiers that like that's
absolute lunacy that's interference like
that's the election tampering
big thank you to miken larsen who is new
member number seven today also
cole smith has signed up in his new
member number eight
very much appreciate that and thanks to
some really strongly
gifted subs on twitch by jeremiah
uh that puts us at 13. i have no problem
with 13. i know there's people who are
all
broken up about 13 but i have no problem
whatsoever with 13.
beautiful number red rover says trump
let's give as many of them corona as
possible stuff them into a low ceiling
room revenge is mine
you know i know you're kidding but it's
abundantly clear at this point
that donald trump's plan is to hand joe
biden
the craziest worst situation he possibly
can
like as bad as trump can make things for
joe biden when joe biden is sworn in
that's his priority that's clearly his
goal at this point
um and they're making it pretty bad
i don't know if you guys saw the new
coronavirus numbers but yesterday
um again we're at 2 000 deaths a day
so 2 000 deaths yesterday is the worst
since let's see
it's actually the worst since you have
to wow look at how far back we're going
yesterday was the worst day as far as
deaths go
since may 7th it's been six and a half
months since we had as bad a day as
yesterday
as far as deaths are concerned it's
absolutely insane
uh and and trump has not taken a single
question from a reporter
in i don't even know i mean weak but
wait so let's see
he took questions was it the week before
the election like it's been it's really
been a month before donald trump took
questions from the press
and every single day it's just nothing
on his schedule in fact i can pull up
his schedule for you
um let's see here no public events
scheduled
thursday no public events scheduled
wednesday no public events scheduled
tuesday
lunch with pence on monday golf
on sunday golf on saturday
and then we had this event friday which
we covered where trump bragged about
vaccines
didn't take any questions lunch with
pence
and a meeting with pompeo and mnuchin i
mean it's been weeks since donald trump
has actually taken questions from
reporters it's pathetic
he's completely given up that's exactly
right
lauren says the fact that rudy is
considered legal counsel is a further
reminder of what a circus the trump
administration is
yes very much well said jennifer says
good news monica can't rescind her vote
not allowed and they will proceed with
certifying per the new york times
yeah i'm not even talking about it
anymore because it's so laughable
and ridiculous people now coming into
the room and removing masks uh
as you can tell this woman is texting
when you text
you must pull your mask down otherwise
nobody on the receiving end of your
texts
will understand them now we've got just
the mouth covered but not the nose which
is another good move
what a [ __ ] show
oh my god i guess it's starting soon
thanks to edward mccarran for signing up
at joinpacman.com
jonathan guy and kendall colwell
as well as uh joshua roberts
who are new members 14 15 16 and 17
at joinpackman.com and also big thank
you to three new subscribers on twitch
which puts us at 20.
multiple oh god guys settle in
multiple pathways to victory nevada
arizona wisconsin
michigan pennsylvania and georgia are
all colored in red
so what what i'm expecting is something
like listen
um all we need to do is recount a bunch
of states at a cost of 5 million per
if we can flip two of those states and
get the supreme court to hand
pennsylvania to us
trump wins it's that's the guys the path
is that simple don't you understand
it's it's going to be that easy to get
this election back
this is just disgusting it's disgusting
that they are doing this
and i'm wondering whether they will um
on december 14th when it gets certified
does all this go away do you guys think
i don't know we've got a major hype
train happening on twitch
uh for people watching on youtube and
twitch nightbot is enabled and now has
been better configured
so nightbot i think is functioning i
think it's functioning really pretty
well
and since this is a smaller stream we'll
be able to pay closer
closer attention to it and see exactly
how it's working
super chats continue coming in question
for mike pence would mother be proud
now is mother his mom or his wife
i don't actually remember that
felix says i'm looking forward to taking
the biden vaccine well
i mean listen it's not a biden vaccine
or a trump vaccine
it's a pfizer bioentec vaccine and we've
got a moderna vaccine
and then next year by the way the more
traditionally developed vaccines will
presumably also be uh
also be available the guy up front with
the blue mask looks like a younger david
pakman
blue mask i don't see a guy with a blue
mask
i don't think you mean this guy right
this guy seems older than me
i don't see blue mascot i'm sorry about
that
the conference is supposedly in dc at
republican headquarters love your videos
david
thank you thoughts on sydney powell's
powell and her accusations
baseless so far is what i would say
sam says help my wife went missing
yesterday while walking our dog i will
pay a hefty reward
for information leading to the return of
the dog
thank you sam it sounds like you have
bigger problems there than any i can
help you with
dominic says skipped my super chat lame
uh i'll get back to it after it looks
like this is starting
i have no idea what we are bracing for
here guys this could be this could be
anything
who are these people oh there's rudy
okay
this is gonna be it wow rudy looks not
great
here we go
[Music]
oh god and thank you very much for
coming
uh this is um representative of our
legal team
we're representing uh president trump
and we're representing the trump
campaign
that's horrible when i finish
sydney powell and then and then jenna
ellis will follow me wow and we will
present
in brief the evidence that we've
collected over the last
what a team i guess it is two weeks also
uh
joseph is the jennifer victoria tends to
get here with me
did genova's advisors are working on
this but where the
i guess where the where the senior look
at how much money if they get paid is
being made doing this nonsense
so this is donor money i guess the best
way to describe this is when we began
our representation of the president we
certainly
were confronted with a very anomalous
set of results
the president way ahead on election
night seven or eight hundred thousand
red mirage as expected somehow he lost
pennsylvania
right we have statisticians willing to
testify more people voted for by just
impossible to have happened in the
period of time that it happened
but of course that's just speculation
that's right as we started investigating
uh both our investigations and every
number of witnesses very um
let me mute this sorry guys forward our
extraordinary
extraordinary number of people
extraordinary number of witnesses
and what emerged very quickly is because
it's not a singular voter fraud in one
state
broad this pattern repeats itself in a
number of states almost exactly the same
pattern
which to any experienced investigator
prosecutor would suggest like rudy
a plan from a centralized place
to execute these various acts of voter
fraud
specifically focused on big cities voter
fraud
specifically focused on as you would
imagine
big cities controlled by democrats
the idea of calling this an
investigation is also playing pretty
fast and loose with the english language
the number of voter fraud cases in
philadelphia
could fill a library just a few weeks
ago there was a conviction
for voter fraud and one two weeks before
that
and i've often said
this is the smirk of someone who is not
about to win anything guys the only
surprise i would have
found in this is that philadelphia
hadn't cheated in this election that
would have been shocking because for the
last 60 years
they've cheated in just about every
single election
you could say the same thing about
detroit each one of these cities are
cities that are controlled by democrats
which means they can get away with
anything they want to do
right it means they have a certain
degree of control over
certainly control the election board
completely
and they control law enforcement and
unfortunately
they have some friendly judges that will
issue
friendly judges irrational opinions
just to come out in their favor so let's
start with the specifics this is the
best
pennsylvania in pennsylvania the margin
of victory now
for biden which is a
not a victory it's a fraud is 69
140 votes
the reality is that we are now at a
count
of 682 770 ballots
for which we have affidavits that there
was no inspection of that ballot
at the time that it was entered in the
vote
now remember in court yesterday rudy
said we are not alleging fraud in
pennsylvania
in court that's what he actually said
jimmy carter president jimmy carter
and secretary baker in a report
about a dozen years ago in which they
said that male balloting
is particularly uh susceptible
of fraud that we should very carefully
consider ever doing it
and that it can be taken advantage of
this is why the suitor warned us of the
same
thing in a comment in a election law
case
and even the new york times wrote
articles
about how dangerous male voting
mail and voting was and um this is the
first time we ever did it on mass
and i think we proved that uh all three
are profits
he thinks there's been proof of
something already it is easily
susceptible to fraud
particularly if you have a plan or
scheme
which sounds eerily similar to what joe
biden
told us a few days before the election
that he had the best voter fraud team
in the world joe biden just missed it's
like a verbal typo
they were that good because they made
significant mistakes
like all crooks do and we caught them
one of them was pushing out republican
inspectors
every state almost every
civilized country even tanzania and
places you know you wouldn't think of
have uh
bit whole countries even particularly
for mail-in ballots
and why particularly mail-in ballots
because they can more easily be
defrauded and you can't check on it
people who have never done a mail-in
ballot i'm going to show you why it's so
easy
yeah well you fill out an envelope
like this you put your
usually in new york would be yours your
assembly district
and the and the precinct in which you're
voting you fill out your name and your
address
and you sign it you then
use an inner envelope and you put the
ballot inside the inner envelope
you seal it all and you send it in when
it's being
when it's being counted almost
invariably in the united states
up until the mass cheating that went on
in this election
a republican and a democrat inspector
you guys convinced yet
parties is allowed to watch the
unsealing of this ballot
used to go on all over america when we
conducted honest elections
because the only time you can ever find
out
if it's a fraudulent ballot is when it
is looked at
the minute you approve this it's thrown
away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is the vote
that could have been mickey was that
scrap of paper i could have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out
probably he's saying there was a dead
person
in the envelope the same person 30 times
that could have been all these things
have happened by the way right
that could have been um nothing filled
out
we never know so for example the recount
being done in georgia
will tell us nothing the question here
remains the same one which in court the
answer to was no
and he's getting really sweaty do you
have actual evidence of specific
voter fraud and the answer is no because
for example in pennsylvania where we
have probably our most precise evidence
682 770 of these ballots were
cast put in and they weren't inspected
which renders them ballots that are null
and void
cannot be counted have to be removed
from the
from the vote uh why
for several reasons not the least of
which is
that was basically king louis xiv
reportedly voted 40 times for biden can
you imagine
the other parts of the state there was a
legitimate
inspection of the ballots so if you have
two different standards in different
parts of the state
one favoring one part of the state the
other disfavoring the other part of the
state
that's a classic violation of the equal
protection clause of the united states
constitution imagine
getting paid 20 grand a day to do what
rudy is doing right now
that that that teaches that
that's not the only fraud that went on
in pennsylvania
all of the other frauds carried out in
the other states
by the democrat uh bosses
boss that happened there as well the
bosses
jimmy degan did it if you made a mistake
in that ballot and you lived in
philadelphia or in pittsburgh
uh you were allowed to fix the mistake
but if you lived in the what would be
considered more
republican or trump par parts of the
state
you were given no such uh right
one of our plaintiffs mr henry cast a
absentee ballot
and he failed to put it
in the rudy is about to have actual
drops of sweat coming off of his brow i
mean
is this a normal amount i don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here
because it was invalid because that
breaks the um
privacy of the of the vote
in pittsburgh and
in philadelphia if they noticed that
there wasn't an inner envelope
they'd contact the voter and allow him
to vote again or if he didn't fill it
out completely
or if he made a mistake and didn't sign
his full name
he was allowed to cure it there is no
such provision under the law of
pennsylvania
the democrat secretary of state made
that up
right in order to maximize the vote in
philadelphia and pittsburgh
and to minimize the votes in the other
parts of the state clearly illegal
clearly voter fraud easily provable
hundreds of witnesses maybe thousands
we have to give you another example
please we have 17 000 provisional
ballots cast in pittsburgh
do you know what a provisional ballot is
no explain it rudy visional ballot
usually happens this way
and about 15 of the 17 000 happen this
way you walk in
and you say i'm here to vote today
oh mr giuliani you already voted
i did i don't remember voting
oh yes yes you cast an absentee ball he
really paints a picture of the event yes
you did no it didn't yes you did
so why does that happen 17 000 times
in pittsburgh people walked in thinking
they actually fifteen thousand you know
one of the funny things i don't i'm not
going to interrupt
constantly but sometimes one of the
reasons you have so many provisional
ballots is when republicans have done a
really good job at purging voter rolls
people who believe they were registered
but but republicans got them removed
show up to vote and they're told you're
not registered that's one of the main
drivers of out of provisional ballots
when there's these mass
purges and people are like i've always
voted i should be registered no mr
giuliani you're not actually registered
they were instructed by the democrat
bosses
when they had a ballot in which there
was no one registered
right just assign it to somebody just
assign it to rudy giuliani
so when rudy julia and maybe rudy
giuliani won't show up to vote
and if he does show up to vote we'll
give him a provisional bout
that is what we call circumstantial
evidence i don't know guys it's sounding
like trump
won isn't it based on this that in fact
that's what happened to them
as well as the 50
to 60 witnesses we have for the way they
were treated
50 and not allowed to inspect the
ballots
they weren't just um not allowed to do
it
they were pushed a few cases they were
assaulted
insulted in all cases they were put in a
corral right
so far away probably the closest they
got they were
even given uh a cow feed not only were
they corralled they were given food
normally reserved for for steer
you know the movie it's one of my
favorite war movies because he comes
from brooklyn
and when the the nice lady who said she
saw
and then he uh he says to her how many
fingers do i how many fingers do i got
up
and she says uh three
well she was too far away to see it was
only two
these people were further away right
than my cousin vinnie was from the
witness
they couldn't see a thing now i don't
know
you're going to tell me that 60 people
are lying the poll workers were
reportedly caged
they swore on the penalty of perjury
which is something no democrats ever
done
you don't even ask biden about this
you don't put him under penalty of
perjury right
he doesn't even get asked questions
about he doesn't get asked questions
about
all the evidence of the crimes that he
committed
these people are under penalty of
perjury their names are on an affidavit
they swear that they weren't allowed
to carry out their functions do you
think rudy thinks he's explaining this
coherently
did it why would you not allow
people to carry out the function they've
been allowed to do for
50 years 60 years why wouldn't you allow
inspections of those ballots
because you knew you were going to use
those ballots
to catch biden up
and you had a big road ahead of you you
had to catch him up for 700
000 to 800 000 votes that he was behind
right and the only way you were going to
do it
were with the mail-in ballots you
couldn't have a democrat
and republican inspector around they
don't even have democrats watching it
because they were afraid that they'd be
honest democrats who would say
that's genius they didn't let
republicans watch by the way they didn't
let democrats watch either because
they were suspicious the democrats would
be on they were cheating
that's an unfalsified i mean so so
basically there's no evidence of
anything one way or the other
show you her affidavit because i know
you keep reporting
falsely that we have no evidence that we
have no specific acts of fraud
that's because the coverage of this has
been almost as dishonest as the scheme
itself
right the american people are entitled
to know this
you don't have a right to keep it from
you don't have a right to lie about it
how great would it be if like the
fumigator you know the people spraying
who sanitize the rooms just start
sanitizing behind rudy as this is going
on they thought sorry sir we saw you
thought the event was over we thought
you were just ranting
or uh give you her name
i can't give you all these affidavits
because if i do
these people will be harassed they'll be
threatened
right they may lose their job
they will lose their friends they can't
give us in this case because they've
been threatened
we've had lawyers that need protection
what's going on in this country is
horrible
and the censorship that you're imposing
is making it worse
but jesse jacob is an adult citizen and
a resident of the state of michigan
she's been an employee of the city of
detroit for decades
i know her age but
she can tell you her age she was um she
was assigned to
um voting duties in september and she
was trained by the city of detroit
and the state of michigan she was
basically trained to cheat
she said that i was instructed by my
supervisor
to adjust the mailing date of these
absentee ballot packages
to be dated earlier than when they were
actually sent in
the supervisor made that announcement
for all workers
to engage in that fraudulent practice
that's not me saying that that's just
american citizens saying that
so i want everybody to understand
affidavits
are affidavits proof no affidavits
are typically admissible evidence in a
trial so you could bring an affidavit to
court you instead of bringing the person
you bring the affidavit and the court
would determine whether it's admissible
now there are courts that would say
great we have an affidavit we've got to
bring the person in to actually testify
in court and be subject to
cross-examination
and then a jury or a judge would decide
is it credible evidence so
an affidavit is much like a witness who
asserts something it is evidence it is
not proof and it would be up to a
quarter jury to decide do we believe
it's credible or not but
saying the fact that affidavits exist
that's like saying
i have witnesses therefore i am guilty
or not guilty well
hold on a second they exist but is
what do they say but you can't just
throw it away
gee there's no evidence next time you
say that you'll be lying
because there is evidence this oh by the
way this is public you can all
get it it's attached to the complaint in
constantino versus the city of detroit
then she was instructed by my supervisor
not to ask for a driver's license or any
photo id
when a person was trying to vote
don't ask for an identification why
would you not ask for identification
because you knew that a lot of people
not entitled to vote
were going to come in an early vote
because you knew that illegal
immigrants were going to be allowed to
vote you knew
if you lived in philadelphia unless you
do not that's an italian expression for
stupid
unless you're stupid you knew that a lot
of people were coming over from camden
to vote
they do every year happens all the time
what camden new jersey
people from new jersey so in
pennsylvania if you
don't have a driver's license you can
just give the last four of your social
so again you know without knowing more
details we just have no idea what rudy's
talking about
and has been for years
many many years and they carried it out
in places they could get away with it
they didn't carry it out in neutral
places they didn't carry it out in
republican places
they didn't carry it out where the law
is respected they carried it out in
corrupt
a corrupt city where the district
attorney releases criminals
on mass which is why it has so much
crime
she also said i observed a large number
of people
who came to the satellite location to
vote in person
but they had already applied for and
submitted an absentee ballot
so she observed a lot of people voting
twice
again this is
[Applause]
this is the law jacob not me
i was instructed not to valid not to
invalidate any ballots
and not to look for any deficiency in
the ballot
why would you do that because you're
cheating
on purpose cheating intentionally
cheating
you're cheating as a institution this is
an instruction
from the election commissioner or the
the employer
to the worker don't look for any
deficiencies in the balance
i was instructed not to look at any of
the signatures
the absentee ballot if she was
instructed to look
not to look for any of the signatures on
the absentee ballots
why the heck do you sign it in the first
place in order to identify it
she was instructed not to do that
because many absentee ballots were
fraudulent
and they knew that there you going to
have a count to that
camera is likely before 2020 i was
instructed to improperly predate
the absentee ballot when the receipt
date was actually november
was was after november 3rd 2020. now
this is really significant
because just everything going on the
supreme court
instructed pennsylvania
that any ballot that comes in after
eight o'clock on november 3rd
2020 had to be put aside and not opened
because there's a question as to its
legality and its constitutionality
what she's telling you is that they
blatantly disregarded that order
that they took ballots that were marked
the fourth and the fifth
and the sixth and they marked it down
for the third
in blatant disregard of the order of the
united states supreme court
this is this is i don't know if she's a
democrat or republican
i assume she's working if she's working
i assume she's working with the city of
detroit that she's a democrat
i assume but i may be wrong she's a
citizen
i've never met her never coached her
never been in a hotel room with her i'd
like you to note
that it's signed under penalties of
perjury
as has been pointed out there are sworn
affidavits that people saw ufo there are
sworn affidavits that people saw bigfoot
doesn't tell you anything the person
could believe that that's what they saw
on the other side we don't do that to
them
they've done that to a lot of our people
they've done it for four years
and it's outrageous that it's tolerated
and it's tolerated
because you condone it right in the
press it's the media's fault
you don't condemn it and it shouldn't
happen to a republican or a democrat
a lawyer shouldn't have to withdraw from
a case because he's representing
the president of the united states what
there are many more affidavits here i'd
like to read them all to you but i don't
have the time
you should have had the time and that
you to go look for them
that's your job like it's my job to
defend the president
and represent the president it's your
job to read these things
and not falsely report that there's no
evidence do you know
you know how many affidavits the
difference between evidence and proof is
a relevant
question they're not all public but
eight of them are
four affiants here those are people who
give affidavits
report an incident that under any other
circumstances would have been on the
front page of all your newspapers
if it didn't involve the hatred that you
have irrational pathological hatred that
you have
for the president really going to win
hearts and minds and flip the election
by insulting the media covering the
event
it's like they shouldn't even be
covering the event the fact that there's
even press here is what's crazy
counting ballots the people thought it
was food
so they all ran to the truck oh god that
wasn't true
it was thousands and thousands of
cannoli
and the ballots were in garbage cans
they were in
paper bags they were in cardboard boxes
and they were taken into the center oh
it's just too much they put on a number
of tables
at that time they thought all the
republican inspectors had left
all but two had and an employee of
dominion
right who uh
we will address a little bit later
dominion right and here's what they
jointly swear to that every ballot that
they could see
every thing they could hear these were
ballads
if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his face off
explaining to us why trump really won
the election
down ticket just by
many of them didn't have anything on the
outer envelope
because these ballots were produced very
quickly very swiftly
and they're estimated to be a minimum of
sixty thousand
maximum of a hundred thousand did he say
sixty thousand
people counted which means they were put
into the
counting machine this way once
twice three times
i didn't see that i don't know that but
for the fact that
three american citizens are willing to
swear to it
and we're not going to let them go to
court and do that
we're going to let this election go by
when there are
in this case 60 witnesses for as long as
he can build 20 grand a day he's not
letting this go by that's for damn sure
in michigan i mean what's happened to
this country
if we're going to let that happen what
happened to this country
what the hell how about al gore carry on
an election dispute
longer than this one has been going on
for one state and for chad's
this happened in pennsylvania it
happened in
michigan michigan probably right now
if i count up the affidavits just one
case alone trump v
benson a case that we dismissed today
because
that case was attempting to get the
wayne county board of supervisors
to decertify well they did they
decertified
that case has a hundred affidavits
and the 100 affidavits show essentially
what i've uh talked to you about all
right
counting ballots improperly counting
them three and four times
uh having people having people vote
three and four times
changing and back dating ballots to the
point of at least
three hundred thousand illegitimate
ballots
he's trying to try this in the media but
then when he goes in front of a judge
like he did yesterday
and he's asked are you alleging voter
fraud he says no we're not allowed we're
not alleging that at all
it's like present this to courts every
time they've done it
they're shot down the election in in
michigan if you take out wayne county
so it's a very significant case that is
being raised in the case of constantino
versus the city of detroit ah not by us
but by an individual plaintiff
we are helping and assisting in that
case however
and you can find all the affidavits that
you want
filed in that case and you can find out
they're not just
allegations they're allegations
supported by
sworn testimony again testimony is just
an assertion
he doesn't answer questions it's not
proof for david's
wisconsin wisconsin had a very small
margin
oh no 21 20 544 last time i looked
in wisconsin without going into great
detail
very similar plan republicans shut out
in the city of milwaukee and also in
madison
republicans almost uniformly shut out
from the absentee
process not allowed to inspect not
allowed to look at the ballots
we have in milwaukee and in the state of
wisconsin
a much stricter law wisconsin doesn't
allow
mail-in ballots they didn't buy into the
big mail-in ballot
situation oh wisconsin
when you look at their constitution
almost seems to not like absentee
ballots
they state it's not a right a privilege
and they have
very very strict procedures and
the strict procedure says that you can't
be given an absentee ballot
you have to personally apply for it it's
illegal
basically to solicit a vote and they
have
actually many reasons for it it probably
goes back to their
their progressive days when i say
progressive
i mean late 19th century early 20th
century progressive
when that really meant progresses not
retrogressive
so there are sixty thousand ballots
in milwaukee county and forty here's the
summary of this press event
if we get to choose which votes count in
each state
based on who they voted for trump wins
that's the that's the press conference
that don't have applications
under the law of the state of wisconsin
already decided if there's no
application
for an absentee ballot the absentee
ballot is thrown away
this all happened in two places
whoa what the hell just happened did it
just get cut
private video what on earth just
happened
rnc press conference let's see if we can
find it
what on earth just happened
what the heck
that is bizarre we'll have to find a new
feed okay
let's go to a new feed holy geez
procedures
there were no no inspectors provided for
the count of the illegal ballots
there were numerous backdated ballots
we're just counting them now
run over into the thousands and there
were many precincts in which there was
an overvote
now let me explain to you what an
overvote is i'll find better quality
you should have explained to the
american guy because it's about the
clearest circumstantial evidence of
massive fraud that you can have
an overvote is if 200 of the people who
are registered
in the district vote think about that
200 of the registered voters in the
district
vote what does that mean that means
somebody voted twice that means somebody
who's not entitled to vote
voted and illegal a person from another
city
illegal a person is not registered
but what it means is that those are
illegitimate votes
you don't have an overvote of 200 or 300
percent
you don't have an overvote of 100 most
most
uh precincts don't have 100 turnout
in fact classically it's considered to
be an overvote if you go over 80
well in michigan and wisconsin
we have over votes in numerous precincts
of 150 200
and 300 percent one of the reasons why
the two republicans did not certify
in wayne
michigan wayne county michigan is
because the overvote
was so high monstrously high
in about two-thirds of the precincts in
the city of detroit which means
magically
two and three times the number of
registered voters turned out to vote
in fact we have precincts in which here
we go two times
that means somebody voted twice
that means somebody who's not entitled
to vote voted
and illegal a person from another city
or state
a little behind a person is not
registered
but what it means is that those are
illegitimate votes
you don't have an overvote of 200 or 300
percent
you don't have an overvote of a hundred
percent an overvote most
uh precincts don't have 100 turnout
in fact classically it's considered to
be an overvote if you go over 80
well in michigan and wisconsin
we have over votes in numerous precincts
of 150 200
and 300 percent one of the reasons why
the two republicans did not certify
in wayne
michigan wayne county michigan is
because the overvote
was so high right monstrously high
in about two-thirds of the precincts in
the city of detroit which means
magically
two and three times the number of
registered voters turned out to vote
in fact we have precincts in which two
times the number of people who live
there
including children voted
that's absurd
the frustration of this is what i'm
describing to you was a massive
fraud it isn't a little teeny one
is he okay it isn't you know 100 votes
switched here or there
georgia we're about to file a major
lawsuit in georgia
huge lawsuit that'll be filed probably
tomorrow i don't need to go through it
virtually the same things i've told you
before very
in the city of atlanta
republicans were not allowed to watch
the absencey
mail-in ballot process inspections
completely cast aside and
we have numerous double voters we have
numerous
out-of-state voters and we have
specific evidence of intimidation and
changes of vote
that'll all be in the lawsuit that comes
out duty is melting arizona
is okay as a state that we're looking at
very very carefully strongly looking at
it i would say we're probably going to
bring a lawsuit in arizona
i think we are going to bring a lawsuit
in arizona we're still collecting that
evidence they have 25 days before
certification
surprise you is we have very very
significant
amount of fraud allegations in the state
of new mexico
which
we have a significant number of
allegations in the state of virginia
i don't know yet whether the number in
virginia will reach the number that can
turn
uh the election in the states that we
have indicated in red
georgia pennsylvania michigan wisconsin
is he bleeding did you see is he
bleeding from his ear
what on earth was that votes needed to
overturn the election
in terms of provable illegal ballots
oh it's on both sides to find out if i'm
does that hair die is to look at the
lawsuit
holy look what's alleged look at the
affidavits
maybe we can supply more affidavits in
order to do it it looks like
blood
that come from citizens we have
we have a thousand at least and we're
getting he's got to get off the stage
and there are other aspects of this
fraud that at this point
i really can't reveal this is really
enough
it's enough to overturn any election
it's disgraceful what happened
and i'll conclude by asking you to just
think about this for a minute
what happened on the morning of november
someone's got to get him a napkin and
they were going to count
the these this new kind of battle
i've never seen anything like this did
every democrat
leader in pennsylvania what on earth
it's getting onto his shirt now michigan
and in wisconsin and in georgia
and in nevada and in arizona they all
wake up
and all separately have the same idea
do they all separately have the idea
that we are going
to we're going to put republican
inspectors in oh my god
we're not going to let them look at
mail-in or absentee ballots
they all independently come up with that
like
just by coincidence they say hey you
know we're going to put
we're going to put the republicans in
pens and corrals
we're going to do it in pittsburgh we're
doing in philadelphia we're going to do
it in detroit
we're going to do it in milwaukee we're
going to do it in las vegas
i'm going to do it in phoenix what did i
miss oh we can do in atlanta what what
is he talking about
or isn't the logical conclusion
that i think any jury would accept if
they heard this evidence
that somebody had this plan this is
insane maybe that was always the plan
to do these this very very questionable
form of voting
which has been criticized by president
carter
by secretary baker by most experts on
election reform
i think the logical conclusion is if
you're just joining us rudy giuliani's
face seems to be melting
black liquid is coming down his face
and it comes from the candidate clearly
that's the reason why hillary clinton
said don't concede
even if you're losing that's the reason
we had a freudian slip by the candidate
freudian and he said he had the
best voter fraud team this whole thing
is kafka-esque
that's the reason why he probably didn't
have to go out and campaign god are we
sure that's not blood
he had to have known what they were
going to do this had to be planned in
advance
is that hair dye gathering right at the
corner of the sideburn and coming down
i don't know what that is contracted to
get the corrals
to put the republicans in and this is a
disgraceful thing that was done in this
country
probably not much more disgraceful than
the things these people did in office
which you didn't and don't bother to
cover and you concealed from the
american people
but we let this happen you know we use
largely a venezuelan voting machine
in essence to count our vote we let this
happen we're going to become venezuela
we're almost venezuela oh my god not
allow these crooks because that's what
they are to steal an election from the
american people
stunning they elected donald trump oh
the black stuff is on his shirt now
they didn't elect look at his left shirt
caller joe biden
is in the lead because of the fraudulent
ballot
the illegal ballots that were produced
and that were allowed to be used after
the election
was over give us an opportunity to prove
it in court
i think someone it's like it looks like
sap from an oak tree
or a maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup to describe to you
what we can describe about another
tour and we continue to be listening to
this update from president trump's
legal team some of you are going to be
taking a quick two minute breaks oh wait
we don't want that
let's go back over here oh this woman's
talking now i just detailed
affidavit i don't like this video though
i think this is better let's see
that specializes in voter fraud
i'll let sydney describe that to you oh
my god it's all over his
face thank you rudy what a bizarre event
he's gonna need a towel dealing with
here and uncovering more by the day
is the massive influence asking for
water now
through venezuela cuba and likely china
and the interference with our elections
here in the united states and venezuela
dominion voting systems the smartmatic
technology software and the software
that goes in other computerized voting
systems here as well
not just dominion were created in
billions of
in venezuela at the direction of hugo
chavez
sure he never lost an election after one
constitutional right
has to be set up the way he did not want
it to come out
we have one very strong witness who has
explained how it all works
his affidavit is attached to the
pleadings of lynn wood
and the lawsuit he filed in georgia
it is a stunning detailed affidavit
because he was with
hugo chavez while he was being briefed
on how it worked
he was with hugo chavez when he saw it
operate
to make sure the election came out his
way that was the express purpose for
creating this software
he has seen it operate and as soon as he
saw
the multiple states shut down the
voting at the on the night of the
election
he knew the same thing was happening
here that that was what had gone on
now the software itself there's so many
variables and so many
back doors that can be hooked up to the
internet this is mental illness right
or whatever but one of its most
characteristic features
is is its ability to flip votes
it can set and run an algorithm that
probably ran
all over the country to take a certain
percentage of votes
from president trump and flip them to
president biden
there's no evidence never have uncovered
by the way
but did she say president biden in so
many of these states
that it broke the algorithm that had
been plugged into the system
and that's what caused them to have to
shut down in the states they shut down
in
that's when they came in the back door i
think she just conceded
through the back door alex many of which
they had actually
fabricated some were on pristine paper
with identically matching perfect paper
perfect circle
dots for mr biden
others were this is the tiger king woman
right put in
a certain number of batches and people
would rerun the same batch
this corresponds to our statistical
evidence that shows incredible spikes
in the vote counts at particular times
and that corresponds to eyewitness
testimony
of numerous people who have come forward
and said they saw the ballots come in
the back door at that time
notably the dominion executives
have are nowhere to be found now
understand that she's claiming that that
they just
programmed this to for biden to win like
they just said oh yeah just biden wins
one of the leaders of the dominion
project in overall is
lord malek brown mr soros number two
person
did she say lord malik brown is that was
that what she said lord
as of the dominion leadership to the
clinton foundation
and to other foundations known
politicians in this country
just to give you a brief description of
how this worked
i'm going to quote from a letter that
was written
and i will read that to make sure i get
the quotes right
this person was objecting to the united
states acquisition
of sequoyah voting systems by smartmatic
a foreign-owned company
i believe this transaction raises
exactly the sort of foreign ownership
issues
that cepheus is best positioned to
examine for national security purposes
it's undisputed that smartmatic is
foreign owned and it is acquired sequoia
they keep changing the names
as they go along different times when a
problem comes up they just create
another corporation
they reportedly made this deal at the
maz
eisley tavern on alderaan that's the
crazy thing about when this was all
conceived
were used to record over 125 million
votes
during the 2004 presidential election in
the united states
smartmatic now acknowledges that antonio
mujica a venezuelan businessman
has controlling interest in smartmatic
but the company has not revealed who all
the smartmatic owners are
according to the press smartmatics
owners are hidden through a web of
offshore private entities
and that is in fact true smartmatic has
been associated with the venezuelan
government led
by hugo chavez which is openly hostile
to the united states
and of course as we all know communistic
and
really uh brutalizing its own people the
system has been continued there
by mr maduro and majority
to the venezuelan government poses a
potential national security concern in
the context of its acquisition of
sequoia
because electronic voting machines are
susceptible to tampering
and insiders are in the best position to
engage in such tampering
this letter expresses concern of the
chicago 2000 2006 primary election
and it ends by saying the the products
and services that are
venezuelan origin and evaluate swine i
hope that the 60 000 of you that are
watching this with me right now
recognize how insane it is for them to
come up with a straight face for rudy to
melt half his face off
and then for sydney powell to say hugo
chavez
cuba communists and venezuela
rigged dominion voting machines
involving the clinton foundation
to steal the election for joe biden mark
this moment
my friends face these concerns as
recently as december 2019.
why our government has not taken them
seriously is beyond my comprehension
unless they have some of the
three-letter agencies have used them
themselves
in other parts of the world we know that
the technology was exported to
affect an election in argentina that's
admitted by
our friend who wrote the affidavit about
hugo chavez and his interest in
smartmatic
again in 2006 carolyn maloney wrote the
honorable john snow the secretary of the
treasury about the issues
speaking of smartmatics leadership one
of the
smartmatic patent holders eric coomer i
believe his name is
is on the web that's too perfect as
being recorded in a conversation with
antifa members saying that
he had the election rigged for mr biden
nothing to worry about here and he was
going to they were going to
i can't take it guys his social media is
filled with
hatred for the president and for the
united states of america as a whole
as are the social media accounts of many
other smartmatic
people oh it's too much there has been
widespread use of this
dominion itself is utilized in 2000
jurisdictions in 30 states
it has been uncertifiable in multiple
states who realized all the problems
that it had
including texas experts have described
it
across the board from a print a
princeton group of three professors
to experts that we have talked to
about its end user vulnerabilities
people can admittedly go in and change
whatever they want they can set the
ratio of votes
from one thing to another they can say
that people should be in prison
1.25 and a trump vote counts as 0.75
right and those may be the numbers that
were actually used here
it's not just the swing 1.25 the
algorithm was likely run
across the country to affect the entire
election
like i said we only discovered it this
year because
of the i hope somebody clipped votes
for president trump in the swing states
that caused the machines to have to shut
down
for them to backfill for adding votes
we have evidence of different numbers of
votes being injected into the system the
same
injected votes six digit number
multiple times in at least two states
that we've analyzed so far and i'm
talking about like
341 542 votes
for biden and 100 0012 for trump
um there's no explanation no logical
explanation for the same numbers being
injected 20 minutes apart
into the machine
manual saturday night live is out of
business and i would encourage you all
to read it
because it specifically advertises some
of these things as features
of the system why it was ever allowed
into this country is beyond my
comprehension and why nobody has dealt
with it is
absolutely appalling the machines were
easily accessible to hackers there's
video on the net that
will explain to you how a kid with a
cell phone
can hack one of these voting machines
baron even
there's been no oversight of dominion or
its software
workers in each county were trained by
dominion but there's no evidence of any
monitoring otherwise
we have testimony of different workers
admitting that they were trained how to
uh dispose of trump votes and
add to biden votes they incinerated the
future pursuant to which you can drag
and drop
any number of batches of votes to the
candidate of your choice or simply throw
them away
so we have mathematical evidence in a
number of states of massive quantities
of trump votes being trashed
just simply put in the trash like you
would on your computer with any file
and biden votes being injected
that's addition to the flipping i mean
it really happens in two ways there's an
algorithm that runs
that automatically flips all the votes
and then each operator has the ability
to go
the biden votes were injected so many
times they now have
autism just like with the mmr vaccine
conspiracy theories
can go down ballot and select who would
they want to change the results for
mr um
the gentleman who founded the huma yeah
the guy on the internet
explaining that yes at least one
occasion he admits
they changed a million votes with no
problem
yep changed a million votes just like
that many of the jurisdictions that have
had this problem
might not have known of the issues
but many did and i think a full-scale
criminal investigation needs to be
undertaken immediately
by the department of justice and by
every state's
equivalent attorney general's office or
state investigatory unit
because there are there's evidence of
different benefits being provided to the
people who spent 100 million dollars of
taxpayer money at the last minute
for their state to get the dominion
voting systems put in in time for this
election
in different ways there's one person
that a lawyer told me got quote election
insurance
meaning that he would be able to make
sure he was elected
i'm sure they explained that feature in
detail to
many people who expressed interest in
putting this voting system in
texas denied certification of the
dominion system in 2019
but there are no doubt issues with the
software that texas did use
unbeknownst to texas i would imagine
since they went to great trouble to
examine the dominion systems and reject
them
right but other software the source code
that does the alterations is embedded we
have been told in the source code
all across the country and all the
voting machines
there's no doubt it has been used to
alter elections in other countries
we know specifically that venezuela
exported it for that purpose to
argentina
right and other latin american companies
to make sure that the corrupt rulers who
were willing to pay the highest price
for being in office were allowed to
rig their elections this is stunning
heartbreaking infuriating
and the most unpatriotic are you going
to cry
acts i can even imagine
for people in this country to have
participated in
in any way shape or form and i want the
american public to know right now
that we will not be intimidated and
patriots are
fed up with the corruption from the
local level to the
highest level this should be a 72-hour
cycle
this country back we are not going to be
intimidated we are not going to back
down
we are going to clean this mess up now
president trump won by a landslide we
are going to prove it
and we are going to reclaim the united
states of america for the
people who vote for freedom right
how come you're not suing in the
wisconsin counties that use this why are
you only doing a read
excuse me that we're not out to the
questions at this point oh god
so excuse me we're not at the questions
at this point my name is jenna ellis and
i'm the senior legal advisor
uh to the trump campaign and i'd like to
just explain now
uh where we've been and where we're at
and what you can expect from this
process
what was that guy's name jason coomer
who is is he going to be speaking here
papers tomorrow will be one of two
things either
there was not sufficient evidence that
we've presented or
we spoke too long okay so what you've
heard
now isn't basically an opening statement
what you can expect to see when we get
to court
to actually have a full trial on the
merits
to actually show this evidence in court
when will that prove
our case this is not a law and order
episode where everything is neatly
wrapped up in 60 minutes
for those of you it's also a lot not a
law and order episode and they're
in that there appears to be no crime
networks clearly you've never been court
reporters
trials take time putting on evidence
takes time this is basically an opening
statement so the american people can
understand
what the networks have been hiding and
what they refuse to cover
because all of your fake news headlines
are dancing around
the merits of this case and are trying
to delegitimize
what we are doing here let me be very
clear
that our objective is to make sure to
preserve and protect
election integrity president trump has
been saying from day one
that this is about maintaining free and
fair elections in this country
it is not about overturning an outcome
it is about making sure
that election integrity is preserved and
every and wait a second
the last woman said it's about trump
really won she says now it's not
actually about making trump the
president
and if your fake news network is not
covering this or allowing you to cover
it
fairly and accurately you should ask
yourself why
this is absolutely a legitimate legal
basis
we have been asked to provide
an entire case that generally would take
years
in civil litigation i've been a
prosecutor i have tried cases
with far simpler facts one thing
happened
in a matter of minutes and it still
takes days and
we go through a jury process this is the
court of public opinion right now
we are not trying our case in the court
of public opinion because if we were we
would get unbiased jurors
i would strike 99 percent of you from
the jury and i would be allowed to
because of the fake news coverage what
you provide you are not
they are or aren't trying to tell you
step out of your role as a journalist
and actually
go into a courtroom and you are a judge
on a bench
that has sworn an oath to be unbiased if
she had to pick the jury she would be
going i'm gonna strike and strike and
strike
and strike everybody truth matters and
if you are fair reporters
you will cover that fairly and
appropriately and you will allow
coverage
of our media team here and our legal
team
that is absolutely shocking that all you
cover are around the margins
and i've seen all of you taking pictures
right now and i can
anticipate what your headlines are going
to be well yeah if you are
not willing to talk about the evidence
that has been presented
then that is absolutely unacceptable for
journalistic standards
this is an opening statement i guess
this is the attack the media part of the
press briefing
show and we have given you a brief
description
that happens in a courtroom all the time
where that's not
the fact-finding process that is just an
overview
that is what we have given you today
because the american people deserve to
know what we have uncovered
in the last couple of weeks remember
this is such a short time frame
and this is an elite strike force team
that is working on behalf of the
president and the campaign
to make sure that our constitution is
protected we are a nation
of rules not a nation of rulers
there is not someone that just gets to
pick who the next president is outside
the will of the american people
no the people picked already because
when we talk about voter fraud
it's actually election official fraud
that cannot stand the constitution
requires like when lindsey graham
suggested to the georgia secretary of
state could you throw out ballots
that's election fraud it's not voter
fraud what happened
in this case is that state and local
level officials
and all the way up have changed the
rules
that's what the democrats do if they
don't like the rules they change them
and they change them at the last minute
they manipulate them they want to tear
down our american system
our founders were so brilliant that they
anticipated this that there would be
corruption
there would be foreign influence there
would be attempts to manipulate no it's
crazy
the founders didn't anticipate someone
as corrupt as trump who would flout all
the rules and that's why trump has
gotten away with everything
because they never imagined we would
have someone as
corrupt as trump kissy position to
adopt and ratify the electoral college
and the process
by which we select our president we
select our president through the
electoral college not because it
disenfranchises voters
but because it is a security mechanism
for exactly the type of corruption
that we are uncovering and every
american should be grateful and thankful
that our founders had the foresight
to put in those protections and
provisions to make sure
giuliani and digenova look like their
mom is scolding everybody because we
were bad and we're just gonna sit here
and be very very still so we don't get
yelled at too campaign
senior legal advisor a lot to take in
from
this news conference obviously and uh
we're going to break it down right here
for you in just
a moment welcome everyone here what's
going on let's switch back over
we will get there and we have time and
we have constitutional provisions that
will step
in when we show the corruption and the
irredeemably
challenged and overturned votes
that are absolutely corrupt in all of
these counties
it is irredeemably compromised we will
show that but you have to give us that
opportunity this has been just our
opening statement
and we have an opportunity to get there
and we have time
and we will do that this is the united
states of america and we stand proudly
for president donald j
trump questions
[Music]
the world is watching this i have gotten
multiple emails from people in other
countries
who watch the same pattern happen there
we have witness testimony
that the same things were done in those
countries as this was exported from
venezuela and
by maduro and by chavez
and by cuba and of course we know china
also has a substantial presence in
venezuela and substantial interest
in making sure that president trump does
not continue
in office this is the consummate
foreign interference in our election in
the most
criminal way you can possibly imagine
it must be shut down we know for example
that one of the dominion's highest
level employees or officers went to
detroit himself
to man the detroit operations center
where he could watch the votes coming in
real time
and decide what file folder in the
system to put those votes into
that's why you see massive spikes after
hours when people were told
that all the votes were in and all the
votes were counted
many dominion employees have already
reached out to us to tell us the truth
they are americans who want to ensure
election and integrity like we do
i would encourage every dominion or
smartmatic employee who is fed up with
the corruption in this country
to come forward as soon as possible
because these are serious federal
offenses that i am confident the
department of justice
will be in pursuit of in very short
order if they are not already
all right a few questions yeah um mayor
giuliani uh this already reminds us of
30 years ago
they had federal judges doing consent
decrees over elections so he have a
federal judge overseeing
uh the election this year this is old
chicago
will you be asking that in georgia where
you have two the two senate races have
the
u.s district court judges and federal
authorities monitoring elections
i i can't say what's going to be done
about that we have sort of a uh
operation i'm sorry pennsylvania yes
atlanta is sort of an operation
i i i know about it i really can't give
you an opinion on that
uh i think obviously every election
official should learn something from
this
and be very very careful with the next
election i know this is a lot of
information that we've given you
uh information probably because we're
frustrated with
what we keep reading and hearing in the
censored press which is that we have no
evidence
we have no specifics they've got to get
rudy off stage back up of what we're
saying
and you largely ignore the affidavits
that are filed
whether you agree or disagree with an
affidavit
it's evidence you can't say i mean
you're just
lying to the american people when you
say there's no evidence
sydney was giving you information that
come from affidavits from other people
that are given under oath i was
explaining things to you from affidavits
that come from other people american
citizens
who swear under oath that they saw one
hundred thousand
ballots come in and that they were all
for joe biden
and that i should point out now that
sydney has spoken
right those happened just around the
time
that the dominion or smartmatic
people call the hall to the election and
then
you can also trace it with a very big
spike in the vote count
at exactly that time right up
so what we're telling you is supported
by
evidence and
we're going to have to present these
because of the procedures that exist
according to the different voting laws
of the different states for example you
asked us about
wisconsin we have to first create a
contest in wisconsin
before we can move to bringing a
uh fulsome federal lawsuit
the contest from everything i can see is
going to overturn i
see a lot of people just tuning in
asking why why it looks like rudy
giuliani has blood
running down both sides of his face
apparently that's hair dye which seems
to be coming off the point of his
sideburns it's been dripping it does
look like dried blood but apparently
it's brown hair dye
it started dripping about an hour ago
and
it's still coming down we that's really
all we know the application
and the reason it keeps all these things
together is precisely to avoid
what the democrats did in this election
which is to misuse the absentee ballon
process
and the mail-in process in order to
cheat
so they really cheated in two respects
they cheated with the machines
it it instead of asking me
you're asking the wrong questions we're
going to bring a lawsuit in wisconsin
which we will if we have to you should
have asked me
and you should be more astounded by the
fact that our votes are counted
in germany right and in spain
by a company owned by affiliates
of chavez and maduro did you ever
believe that was true
did any of you here believe that that
was possible
of course it's not of course it
shouldn't be passed he almost said of
course it's not possible i don't know if
we're gonna have time
to develop all that yeah i don't think
it's time to
fill the requirements of all these cases
we have enough evidence without that to
overturn
this election we have it from the
affidavits of american citizens
but that's a matter of national security
that we're talking about now
very very serious matter of national
security please don't make light of it
and don't act like you knew it don't act
like it isn't a surprise
right if that's not a headline tomorrow
then you don't know what a headline is
right there isn't a single person in
this country that would have believed
that we have states that are stupid
enough to have our vote
sent out of this country there you
couldn't possibly believe
most of us still don't believe it the
company counting our vote
with control over our vote is owned by
two venezuelans
who were allies of chavez are present
allies of maduro
with a company whose chairman
is a host associate and business partner
of george soros
the biggest donor there's always a rich
jew
somewhere in the conspiracy theory you
have to it's never
complete and the bow is when you can
attach a rich jew to the conspiracy
theory
our people the truth yes
thank you giuliani my name is rsbn
some on this legal team have mentioned
before that
people close to the trump campaign are
pressuring them to drop the
investigation
into dominion can you go further into
detail tell us specifically who those
people are
also if it's possible can you tell us if
they work with some of our powerful
defense groups in the united states such
as the cia
the last part was do they work
with defense groups and the cia first
i've
i'm in charge of this investigation with
sydney and
the people you see here um
there's been no pressure to stop
investigating dominion
in fact there's no there's pressure to
go
go as fast as we can i mean i think
there was uniform shock
when we first heard it i think when i
first heard it i didn't believe it until
sydney showed me the documents
and in fact oh my god he shouldn't turn
like that anymore what we had to do was
go online and find out
that smartmatic is owned by venezuelans
close to
chavez you can google it well unless
they take it down
i preserved it so you can find it not
you know and and
by the way the coomer character coomer
not again
close to antifa oh god took off all of
his
social media there it is again but we
kept it we've got it
the entire case is preserved in hair dye
he wrote horrible things about the
president
he is completely he is completely biased
he's completely warped and
he specifically says that they're going
to fix this election
i don't know what you need to wake you
up
to do your job and inform the american
people
whether you like it or not of the things
they need to know
this is real it is not made up it is not
there's nobody here
that engages in fantasies i've tried 100
cases
i prosecuted some of the most dangerous
criminals in the world
no fantasies here guys smell them you
don't have to smell this one
i can prove it to you 18 different ways
i can prove to you
that he won pennsylvania by 300 000
votes
i can prove to you that he won michigan
by probably 50
000 votes he just needs time guys when i
went to bed on election night
he was ahead in all those states every
single one of those states
how is it they all turned around every
single one of them turned around
or is it more consistent there was a
plan to turn them around
and since there are witnesses who say
there was a plan to turn them around
and it kind of begs credulity to say
that it all happened in every single
specialty what
my goodness this is how you win cases in
a courtroom did he say it begs or it
bangs
[Music]
so credulity you take their own election
our goal here is to go around
the iron curtain of censorship that what
publication are you with
[Laughter]
it's to go around the outreach any
question from cnn is now
not taken seriously and get facts to the
american people
that if you were a fair and honest
network you'd have been reporting for
the last two weeks
these are facts these are things that
actually
happen these people really wrote these
affidavits these affidavits are really
part of the public record
he seems to not understand that the fact
that an affidavit is real
doesn't mean that what's contained in it
is true you don't do it
oh god chanel
come on you have to have a little humor
i don't know where the fbi has been for
the last three years
right i have no idea where the fbi has
been for the last four years
explained to me how the fbi concealed
a memo in the hand what the hell
of brennan to obama what was that
saying that hillary basically made up
the russian closing plot
and now that's gone away what the hell
is going on here
did you guys notice how that thing came
up saying it's over briefly
here they've gone away from it that was
bizarre they put up a
this oh now there's a mouse cursor now
it's back okay
with no audio now there are clear crimes
revealed on it
didn't do anything with that i don't
know where they are now our country
has had its ballots what a mess counted
calculated and manipulated
in a foreign country with a company
controlled
by friends of an enemy in the united
states what do we have to do to get the
fbi to wake up
maybe we need a new agency to protect us
i have no idea
if i might speak for just a minute in
terms of the level of corruption we are
looking at here
we have no idea how many republican or
democratic
candidates in any state across the
country
paid to have the system rigged to work
for them
these people didn't do this just to take
control they may
like she says we don't know how many
people paid to have it rigged well let's
start with evidence of anyone who paid
to have it rigged let's start there
think about the pressure being brought
to bear on
from the social media companies to shut
down free speech
on any challenge to the election this is
a
massive well-funded coordinated effort
to deprive we the people of the united
states
of our most fundamental right under the
constitution
to preserve this republic that we all
cherish
it is of the greatest concern it is the
it is the 1775 of
of our generation and and beyond
sydney yes are votes being held in
process
tabulated overseas there's reports that
there was a piece of hardware
probably a server picked up in germany
is that true
and is it related to them that is true
it is somehow related to this
but i do not know whether good guys got
it or bad guys got it
so question for yes funny first on the
issue of the machine
do you plan to have are you taking a
court order to either
speed or continue or just to gain access
to any of these machines in any of these
contested districts
have you begun that process uh and when
can we expect the timeline what's this
at the top of the screen now
you mentioned in wisconsin and in
michigan these issues are
over voting um where can we learn more
about this
you're saying 150 200 up to 350
in some places
i can only hear one person at the time
now the audio's cycling all right guys
we're gonna call it here because this is
trash um i am gonna be back with another
stream
you're gonna get a rare treat today
we're gonna have a second stream later
because uh there's actually a
coronavirus task force briefing later
and they may take questions the trump
coronavirus task force
is meeting in an hour and they're going
to do a briefing at 4 p.m eastern so
we're going to be back we're going to
get two streams today
um so if you're heading out if you're
watching on youtube
hit subscribe that way you'll be
notified later today when we go live
again if you're watching on twitch
please follow if you're watching on
facebook please like so that later today
you'll be notified when we go live
i do want to thank the 55 people who
either signed up on my website at
joinpakman.com
or or grab the twitch sub i really
appreciate it
um join pacman.com you see the coupon
code
fresh start it's an illegal immoral
discount
i hope you'll take it and guys please
send me the clips of the
ini initial a jason coomer antifa
moment which i think will be funny for
social media
uh but this is this is absolutely crazy
i've never seen anything like it
and uh we are going to cut the stream
here and i will be back with you guys in
a few hours for the coronavirus briefing
which
i predict will be as much of a mess as
this one as well see you then